good evening and welcome to this special
edition of eight news now following the
nfl
on cbs i'm john treach the raiders
offensive line
emerged from their protective cloud of
covid caution just in time
to face the buccaneers the baddest
defense in the nfl
the vast majority of preparation was
done via zoom this week
nothing about protecting derek carr was
going to be easy oh
and tampa bay has the greatest
quarterback of all time game six here we
go
allegiant stadium leads the league in
entry gets derek carr the most accurate
pastor of the nfl
versus tom brady the global leader in
agelessness
tied in talent also on display how about
gronk and darren waller
first drive featured a nelson aguilar
highlight reel car
to the x eagle 25 yard gain and then
carr singes the seam
to aguilar touchdown his third of the
season aguilar is
on fire buccaneers respond with brute
force tom brady plows in to tie the game
but the raiders stay in rhythm in the
first quarter derrick carr
to henry ruggs the rookie on the whip
route rugs
makes it a track meet he doesn't lose
those 30-yard gain
daniel carlson he'll take it from here
42 yards
and perfect and derek carr well he's
going to see this and he's going to give
it his approval
that's the political thumb it's the
season 10 to 7
buccaneers in the red zone brady
frothing at the mouth back shoulder
precision to rob gronkowski gronk likes
touchdown
touchdown the raiders take the lead
14-10
but the raiders then go in reverse carr
in trouble
devin white the big sack final 20
seconds
of the half tom brady taking a shot
to scottie miller 50 yards in the air
with no ounce of perfection to spare
21 to 10 bucks lead at half second half
buccaneers get a field goal but raiders
respond
carr to nelson aguilar who has quickly
become jerry rice
carr then slant strike to darren waller
for the touchdown his third of the
season it's a 24-17 one score game
but beware of brady tommy rolls to the
right and fires to chris
godwin 31-20 reminder tom brady is 43
years old
prove it then carr trying to rally the
troops forcing balls into coverage
forcing this one of course
the rare interception collected by
antoine winfield junior
his dad just retired a few years ago
after the buccaneers extended their lead
las vegas tries to extend hope
that hope is rocked out of the raiders
devin white meets derek carr and that's
a wreck
45-20 buccaneers blow out the raiders
and send las vegas to a three
and three record this was supposed to be
a prime time game with raucous raider
nation
smothering tom brady with intimidation
instead it was a sunday afternoon game
in front of no fans that's the way it
goes in 2020.
chris matthews watched from the press
boxes and is at allegiance stadium with
a first person perspective hey there
chris
hey thank you very much johnny i
appreciate that of course what a
disappointing and you know you look at
that score you mentioned at 45
to 20. in that second half in fact in
the fourth quarter when the raiders got
to within four at 24
20 everybody was kind of talking about
hey maybe they can make a game of this
thing but unlike
two weeks ago where the raiders beat
kansas city they were kind of more of a
finesse team
boy i'll tell you what these tampa bay
buccaneers they'll come out and just
smack you in the face
they are a brute and it kind of showed
as the game wore on and that fourth as
they
march on to that big win now it might
also mention that tom brady picks up
four touchdowns in this game so he now
becomes passing drew brees the all-time
passing touchdown leader no surprise
there uh
through for four touchdowns derek carr a
couple of touchdowns and 287 yards
but really tom brady just too much for
these raiders but it was kind of
interesting that second half though john
when
when they kind of got that to within
four points you're thinking hey maybe
the raiders can do something here but
brady was just too much anyway
after the game as the raiders fall to
three and three john gruden talked about
this disappointing loss
really proud of our football team we
have to play better
obviously on defense we're we got better
players we got to play better we will
disappointing credit to tampa bay
they're a good football team
and i think we are too but i'll answer
any questions i can
um the decision to keep the field goal
[Music]
well yeah so excuse me it was a long one
we had it more like two and it was a
24-20 game
at that time with the field goal and we
felt
at home a little momentum we could hold
tampa to at least
a field goal or possibly get off the
field we had them third and twelve
uh unfortunately we had them right where
we wanted them
and they converted on a check down very
disappointed but uh
it's easy to second guess right now but
in hindsight it probably would have done
the same thing
hey john did you see what happened on
the play where jack jackson was ejected
and i guess just in that moment how
important is it
i did not see what he did i was asking
the officials exactly and
i'll have to get there you'll have to
get their interpretation i i believe the
ejection came from new york city
uh they had access to replays perhaps we
didn't
um but losing sam young early in the
game and then losing gabe
with the week that we have had against a
heck of a defense is
is it was tough on us no doubt
john you've always said your defense is
great effort uh when it comes to certain
plays the effort is there but
do you think the town's always there do
they just have to get better as players
well we got to do a better job it goes
back to me uh
obviously missing abram and arnett in
the back end is tough on us
but i'm not making any excuses we did
not get enough pass rush today and if
you don't let if you let tom brady stand
back there and survey the field he's
proven for 20 years
uh and he proved it for 21 years that
he's still one of the very very best
they have an arsenal of weapons
it's a credit to them but we have to
generate a better rush
and uh until we do it's going to
continue to be tough
all right so a lack of a pass rush as
john gruden was mentioned there also boy
the raiders just couldn't get the
their own russian game going we know how
difficult that is against his buccaneers
defense
76 total yards rushing for the raiders
isn't going to get it done of course
now they're off they take off at three
and three they take off to cleveland
next week
and the browns are three-point favorites
over the raiders raiders back on the
road
we'll see what happens we have much more
for you coming here from allegiant
stadium once again the raiders do fall
45 to 20
to the big tough tampa bay buccaneers
reporting live from allegiant
chris matthews 8 sports now kevin
[Music]
yeah thanks chris okay so as you
mentioned obviously not the outcome
that the raiders wanted by any means but
if you know raider nation
they still are gonna make it a party
they're still gonna have some fun and
celebrate and that's what's going on
here at the west gate i'm joined by
deontay
deonte can you tell everyone at home
what we're doing here
man right now we're just having the best
time ever right now like we're at the
westgate hotel
and all of a sudden like you're just a
sea of raider fans just came out of
nowhere
and it warms my heart you know because
being a raider fan since
day one you have to see everybody home
jerseys the creativity of the
costumes here and and the people it was
just all positive right now
and at the west gate there's no other
better place to have a raider party you
know
right because i think every sunday now
we're gonna have silver and black watch
parties over here
and i just really hope that this
continues because it's just exciting
every week
that's awesome and we talk about raider
nation there's only one
fan base i think in the entire world
that would throw a party
for a fan it is actually super fan
gorilla birthday here today and that's
what everyone is celebrating a little
bit ago we saw him cut the cake
you know shake hands hug he's actually
taking photographs now
with fans deontay tell me is there any
other fan base that would do this and
throw a birthday party for a super
fan man last time i checked i don't see
any fan that's going to
be like the raider fans right now like i
mean we're the most passionate we're the
most die-hard
and i'll challenge any fan to say that
that we're not
you know because every year is our year
you know every year we're going to the
super bowl every year that's our
mentality
it's a red i mean silver and black and
that's why i believe
every day you know and everybody that's
here today
oh my god you should see how
awesome well thank you so much deontay
as i mentioned it's gorilla
birthday coming up at five we will talk
to the birthday boy
of course for now reporting live at the
west gate kennedy martin 8 sports now
where's the disco ball that place looked
amazing right
even in defeat the raider nation goes
all out